hey everyone how's it going welcome back
to this crash course series in this
JavaScript tutorial I'm gonna go over
how to create conditionals in JavaScript
we'll start with JavaScript logical
operators get into how to chain if-else
statements together and how to nest
conditionals to create more complex
logic so to begin I need to explain the
JavaScript logical operators because
they kind of underpin a lot of the
conditional statements that we're going
to be covering we already went over a
lot of the arithmetic in comparison
operators in a previous tutorial the
logical operators there's only a few of
them 3 to be exact and they're quite
intuitive so the first up is the and
operator just go right and which when
used with boolean values means that both
conditions have to be met
so both condition1 and condition2 have
to be true in order for the conclusion
to be true it's kind of like this
condition1 and condition2 in real life
terms this is really easy to understand
so to graduate for example you need to
pass both math and science you can see
here that you need both conditions to be
true if you fail either subject if you
fail math or if you fail science then
you don't graduate and in reality we
fail any other subjects you simply don't
graduate
so let's write some code to bring this
home here we go and let condition 1
equal to that would you that's right
that's it the log we just go and run the
so to begin the ampersand sign here you
notice that there's two of them that is
how you declare an end or a logical and
operator in JavaScript now if you just
use a single one of them that's not the
same thing that actually means a bitwise
end and we don't want to get into that
right now
of course we'll get to it into a later
video but just a bit of an advanced
topic so we'll just leave it alone for
now so you can see that condition1 and
condition2 it requires both of them to
be true otherwise the entire conclusion
is false so it would go and change this
let's change this to a true you can see
that this updates and now the conclusion
is true but if we change one of these
again to false then the conclusion is
false so both of these conditions have
to be met for conclusion to be true now
that we've covered and the operator
that's sort of like the opposite of end
is the or operator which is let's just
write this out or which when used with
boolean values means that either
condition 1 or condition 2 has to be
true for the conclusion to be true let's
just comment out all of this for now
that condition 1 equal to be through
let's go and run this the first thing to
note here is that we use these pipe
characters they're called pipe
characters and we use two of those to
declare a logical or operator usually
you see that character right by the
backspace button and again if you just
use one instead of two it actually might
work in the code but what you're doing
is you're using a bitwise or instead of
a logical or so you don't want to do
that see so if we go and play with these
now we can make both of them false and
the overall thing is false after we make
this one true instead you can see that
it only requires one of these to be true
in order for the conclusion to be true
now these two operators were both what's
called binary operators the last one
I'll cover is the not operator which is
a unary operator meaning it operates on
the single operand let's just go here
comment this out and the way to think
about the not operator is like taking
the opposite it's an easy way to check
the opposite condition do you think
about whether or not you want to go
gardening outside you would say if it's
not raining so if it's not raining go
garden outside that's an example of how
not works let's write some more code to
clear that up
conclusion and refresh and conclusion is
true and if you flip this so the
condition was true if you flip this to
true then the conclusion should change
to false there we go so those are the
logical operators in Java Script know
them use them they're super important
for conditionals and now let's move on
to how to create if statements in
JavaScript an if statement is a way to
conditionally execute a block of code if
the conditions are right so let's just
clean up a little bit in here first and
to get rid of all of this and they
generally look like this in JavaScript
let's break this down a bit we use the
if keyword right here and then we have a
condition in here between these two
parentheses followed by these curly
braces and what happens now is if the
condition is true this code here runs
and the code here and here it does not
run
that's if condition 1 is true but if
condition 1 isn't true let's say the
condition 1 is false but condition 2 is
true in that case what will happen is
that it'll check condition 1 first this
code will not run since condition 1 was
false condition 2 will be checked it'll
be true and so this code will run and
this code here and this code here will
not have run and finally the else
statement right here if condition 1
ends up being false and condition2 ends
up being false then this else statement
acts like a fallback if all the other
conditions fail you can run this code
instead so code 3 will run if condition1
and condition2 fail now there's a few
things to note in here there's only one
required part in here and that's the
initial if statement this this block of
code right here everything else is
optional so I can actually get rid of
all of this and this is a completely
valid if statement we don't need the
else if and we don't need the else let's
put this back and I'll get rid of the
else now in addition to the elsif being
optional you can also add as many of
them as you want so I can go and
copy-paste this a few times and I can
add as many of these as I want and what
it'll do is it'll just check them in
sequence so it'll check condition 1 if
condition 1 isn't true it'll move on to
this else if statement it'll check if
condition 2 is true and so on and as
soon as one of these is true the code
inside will be executed and in this case
since there's no else statement if none
of these are true none of these will run
and since the elsif is optional I don't
even need to include it I can include
just an else for examples so depending
on what makes sense for your code you
may need in-house you may need multiple
else ifs add what makes sense for your
code by the way these curly braces here
so we've got one set of curly braces
here and the second set of curly braces
here these are what's called block
statements and they're just a way of
grouping a bunch of code together
basically any code you write either a
single line or many many lines of code I
could have
I can put many many lines of JavaScript
in here you can write it all in the
block statement and the reason I'm
mentioning it is because if you wanted
to nest the if statements you can do it
easily by just writing a second set of
if statements inside the block statement
so to give an example here we've got if
condition one we've got the code in here
but maybe we want to add another check
in here you can see that if condition 1
is true then we will execute all of the
code inside here which in this case is
another if statement let's clear this up
by making this run and print something
I'll make this actually print something
out so that we can be really clear about
what's happening here
if we go and run this so since I said
condition 2 to be false we check the if
statement first we got condition one
here that's true so we're gonna run this
block of code here and we're going to
ignore what's in here and we check if
condition two now and condition2 is
false so then we fall to the else
statement and we log 1 was true 2 is
false now if I go back here and I change
this to true have you run it you can see
that condition 1 is true so we go in
here this passes we run this block of
code condition 2 is true as well so we
run here now if I go and change
condition 1 to be false it doesn't
matter what condition 2 is set to just
run that because there's only a single
check for condition 1 at the start if
this fails
none of this code runs only the code in
the else statement runs and in that case
1 was false and so we print out one was
false and of course you may notice that
these are block statements these are
block statements and so you can continue
nesting if statements or whatever else
you want to do inside there and that's
how to create conditions in JavaScript
but let's walk through an example to
make it really clear let's write a
little program here let's say I'm buying
a car and we're gonna write some
decision-making logic to decide if that
car is a good buy if it's a good fit for
me so to start I'll clean this up
and we're going to put all of this into
a function since that's good practice
it's good encapsulation and we already
learned how to do this so it's good
practice what I'm gonna do here is I'm
gonna set price if price is less than
$10,000 and return true house and let's
run it and what I wrote here was a
function is car good it takes one
argument the price and we do we do a
check here first
on the price and we check whether or not
the price is less than $10,000 if the
car is less than $10,000 let's say that
we want to buy the car otherwise it's
too expensive we don't want to buy the
car and then the example we call is car
good using $15,000 so it's too expensive
and we don't want to buy the car now
let's modify this a bit because a
blanket statement like it's $10,000 is
too expensive maybe that doesn't quite
capture the nuances of the logic we want
to use here so let's add another
argument let's say that I am really
environmentally conscious so I want this
to be an electric car is electric now if
the price is less than 10,000 I'm not
going to buy it
but give the price
well we did here was we added another
argument is electric and what I'm saying
here is that if the price is less than
$10,000 that's fine I want to buy the
car but if the price is less than
$20,000 and it happens to be an electric
car then I'll also buy it because that's
a great price for an electric car for me
and we can continue adding logic here so
let's say now that it's it's electric
but it's one of those short-range
electric cars it really doesn't go very
far so we add another parameter here and
what I say here is that if it's not a
long-range electric car then I don't
want to buy it it doesn't matter whether
or not the price is less than $20,000 I
don't want a short-range electric car I
want to be able to do a lot of road
trips in this car and short-range just
isn't going to cut it and you can see
with relatively little effort what we've
done is we've created a bit more complex
logic here we've decided between
electric or not electric based on the
price whether we factored in whether or
not it's long range or short range and
you can just keep nesting and adding new
statements in here to make the logic
more complex to reflect what you what
you need and there we go we've covered a
bunch today the logical operators
if-else statements and JavaScript and
how to nest and chain these if-else
statements together to form more complex
logic hopefully this example was easy to
follow if not let me know where
clarifications could be made in the
comments below that about wraps up
today's tutorial see you again soon
Cheers